10 Easter eggs in The Last of Us episode
3 In The Rundown gas station you can
briefly see a safe code on the wall a
huge aspect of The Last of Us games
Ellie finds her iconic palm tree shirt
the one she starts off with in the game
Mortal Kombat 2 has replaced the turning
a fighting game Ellie plays with Riley
in The Last of Us DLC the Lifesavers
logo was purposely put in the background
here as Joel and Ellie are
metaphorically and sometimes literally
each other's Lifesavers the first and
last meals Bill and Frank have together
are rabbit with Beaujolais wine Joel's
pistol might actually be from Bill as
we'll later find out Tess and Joel
traded Frank's strawberry seeds from one
the radio playing 80s music at the end
of episode 1 code from Bill and Frank
that there's trouble is luckily Bill's
default playlist which only plays if
bill hasn't reset the countdown meaning
Bill and Frank are already dead by the
time Joel tests and Ellie leave the qz
the car Joel and Ellie leave-in is the
same one from the game while the mixtape
in the glove compartment is labeled mix
for Bill a present from Frank which
plays Linda ronstadt's a long long time
the same song played when they first met
more Easter eggs on my YouTube channel